I was a relatively early investor in  Tesla and think that it's amazing the  degree to which Elon Musk has advanced  and accelerated the electric vehicle  game but given the at least for now  implosion of Tesla stock down 70 for the  year making a veritable joke out of  Twitter and the seeming uh uh complete  abandonment of anything that we might  call Sensible political principles for  Elon Musk I'm wondering whether he's  going the direction of becoming a sort  of a joke trump-like figure and possibly  also damaging his personal finale  financial position much like uh Donald  Trump has done by virtue of making  himself toxic to at least or more at  least 50 percent or more of the country  let me know what you think